there's a pretty interesting new book by
journalist Katherine Jacobson Raymond
and the book is called crooked
outwitting the back pain industry and
getting on the road to recovery now the
book is being criticized by some is just
a way to offer a solution to back pain
by selling this book but there's
actually a lot of really good stuff in
this book and I've been following the
back pain industry for a long time and
the book talks about some of the areas
of the back pain industry that might be
well known to you and some that may not
be so this includes unnecessary
painkiller prescriptions which can lead
to people getting addicted to opiates
and ultimately getting on to heroin in
injections surgeries a so called
chiropractic adjustments we've talked
about chiropractic many many times
before and there is so much here that I
think the average person would be so uh
would benefit so much from learning
about and back pain is one of those
conditions that has been identified in a
group of conditions by for example the
recently deceased dr. John Sarno who is
a controversial figure in in
evidence-based medicine no doubt but dr.
Sarno and many others subscribe to the
idea that there's this group of
conditions that are very common a common
cause of a visit to your primary care
physician
very rarely lead to a definitive
diagnosis as to the source of the pain
or problem and back pain is one of those
headaches GI issues frequent urination
fibromyalgia is on that list and to be
super clear because every time I talk
about this people get mad I'm not saying
that everybody who's been diagnosed with
those conditions has a psychosomatic
condition right I'm not saying that at
all but what I am saying is that much of
what goes on in the diagnosis of these
conditions ultimately leads to nothing
or unnecessary treatments and a really
good example of this is MRIs you will
have a very common situation where
someone goes to their doctor and they've
got back pain all right we do an
examination in the exam room
nothing is obviously wrong so let's do
an MRI MRIs of course are very expensive
and
part of the reason they're expensive is
because of all the bureaucracy and
medical billing and and everything that
exists within our medical system but you
go to this expensive MRI you spend 45
minutes in the MRI machine and you meet
with your doctor to look at it and the
doctor says hey you know what you've got
a disc that looks like it might be
pinched or you've got a vertebra that
appears to be sort of under pressure
the great news is we've got a surgery
that we can do and very often people
will get the surgery done and they might
get some short-term relief and very
often the pain comes back and what is
missing in that if it is that if you
were to go out on the street and recruit
random people who report no back pain
and give them an MRI many of them would
have a similar reign it's got a possible
nerve being pinched there you know that
that vertebra doesn't look exactly right
but they have no back pain and thus you
have many people through this MRI scheme
being diagnosed with a back pain as
caused by something in the MRI when it
may be completely unrelated another sort
of self-fulfilling prophecy that happens
is you've got people who might start to
have back pain maybe maybe as a result
of anxiety or depression or stress or
whatever the case may be and as a result
of the back pain they completely stop
exercise they stop walking etc and that
makes the problem much much worse and
that's led to the development of many
procedures that really rarely work too
well for people spinal fusion surgery
for example this includes the removal of
worn out or injured discs and then the
fusing together of the vertebrae above
and below that that costs a ton of money
average price tag is 80 grand success
rate is 80 percent this is completely
separate from chiropractic work and as
I've talked about chiropractic
effectively pseudo-science many people
report feeling better after they go part
of that it appears to be related to sort
of the endorphins that are released from
the chiropractic visit themselves so you
immediately feel better and then
eventually the pain
was back and you think oh well I need
more chiropractic work to be done these
are just some of the ways Pat in which
this has become a major business and
it's really sad because so many of these
conditions back pain just being one of
them are related to a lifestyle and
related to other things that are going
on in people's lives and so much money
is being made off of it especially
because people are being duped right you
go to a doctor or someone who just seems
to be a medical health professional you
want to be able to trust that person and
if they're offering some pseudoscience
to you you may not even realize that's
what's going on and and so this applies
both to the more pseudoscience solutions
as well as to what I guess we would call
you know evidence-based medicine in the
sense that we're talking about Western
medicine but that's unnecessary in many
cases it's really a sad situation that's
going on with back pain and actually
with a number of other conditions and
the book is very very interesting yeah
the author probably wants to sell books
I don't doubt that everybody's got some
financial incentive but there's some
interesting stuff in there and I
recommend checking it out today's
sponsor is taga dab the hosting
specialist whatever your hosting needs
for your business or project taga dab
can do it dedicated servers virtual
private servers cloud server solutions
colocation custom server solutions and
the big thing at taga dab is their
customer support over seventy percent of
their business comes from repeat orders
and recommendations from existing
customers this is a testament to the
great support that they give their
customers currently rated a nine point
seven out of ten according to the
Trustpilot
review system with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab currently offers our viewers
and listeners a twenty british pound
free credit about twenty four US dollars
to all new customers that sign up gives
you a chance to try the service this is
a limited availability offer for the
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show
to take advantage go to sign up CagA Deb
comm /t DPS and use the
offer code TDPS 20 during account
registration support our sponsors and
support our show in doing so sign up ta
ga da be calm /t DPS coupon code is T
DPS 20